oh bloody odds are you doing you really
want to choke around your restless I
mean it's all fake anyways dude if it
was fake when I Brannon laughs the parts
of my body is left leg bends both ways
well that's nothing you should see his
car sorry penis you should sees penis
we're huge fans thank you so much what
advice would you give us we want to be
the next Q what are your names - what's
your name you walk around here
interrupting the rock here's the rock -
biceps your mouth straight out of the
trailblazing eyebrow-raising
entertaining the glove never hotter tuck
it into rejects from Harry Potter thanks
Wayne
got it welcome to the tryouts you got
other skills
and you have to have a spark my name is
Jerry Lynn and I am going to blow you
excuse me out of the water you put it
together let's keep it one of course
sometimes some of these girls just want
to get famous like cheerleaders models I
was involved all right cheerleader
see you later I have no idea who I'm
supposed to be out there you're not just
doing this view you're doing it for the
family
Paige I myself have come from a
wrestling family too I know exactly what
it means to you but don't worry about
being the next me be the first you
darling
I love you Robin Robin I love you too
love your accident thank you so sexy I
am so jealous of you right now
you
you